-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
There is only one week left
until the midterms.
Said Biden,
"Um, cocaine is legal?"
President Biden
yesterday suggested a tax on
oil and gas companies if they do
not increase production,
because if anyone's concerned
about energy prices,
it's the guy who probably keeps
the thermostat at 78.
New York governor Kathy Hochul
is set to hold a rally
on Thursday with
Hillary Clinton.
"Are you sure
that's a good idea?",
said Hillary Clinton.
President Biden spoke today
in Florida about
the importance of
Social Security and Medicare,
while Republicans
promised seniors
they'd just give them
that pool from "Cocoon."
A very, very fresh reference to
the film "Cocoon."
The New York City Council
last week
passed the so-called
Rat Action Plan
that aims to reduce
the number of rodents
within the five boroughs.
I guess they didn't have any
luck with their previous plan
of piling as much garbage
on the sidewalk as possible.
Come on, guys!
Whose plan was that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Was -- Be honest.
Did a rat give you that plan?
"Uh...
he was a little fella."
CDC director
Dr. Rochelle Walensky,
over the weekend,
tested positive again
for the coronavirus.
So, as per CDC recommendations,
she's taking a half-day.
In a recent interview,
singer Kid Rock said that
he would like to
have a beer with
former president Barack Obama
despite not liking
his policies or voting for him.
In fact, Barack Obama doesn't
even need to be there.
He'll just take
that beer, please.
Utah Senator Mitt Romney
posted a picture yesterday
on Twitter of himself
dressed as Mario for Halloween,
because the scariest thing
he could think of
is a foreigner
taking our plumbing jobs.
A man in South Africa recently
broke a Guinness World Record
by doing 19 consecutive
backbends in one minute.
Said the man, "Uh, right, yeah,
setting a world record.
Uh, yeah, that's what
I was trying to do."
[ Laughter ]
If you're wondering
what that joke means,
Mike Scollins wrote it.
Just work backwards from that.
And, finally,
Netflix's ad-supported plan
will launch this week
for just under $7 a month,
though it will be
free for everyone on
the dad-supported plan.
Somehow, that's a dad joke
at the same time.
"Are you still
on my dad-supported?"
Literally, like, what my dad
would call me up and say.
"You know they're
doing ad-supported.
Not you, though.
You're on the dad-supported."
That was a monologue.
What are you going to do?